Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
The last few years have been an amazing ride
when it comes to research works for creating
facial reenactments for real characters.
Beyond just transferring our gestures to a
video footage of an existing talking head,
controlling their gestures like video game
characters and full-body movement transfer
are also a possibility.
With WaveNet and its many variants, we can
also learn someone’s way of speaking, write
a piece of text and make an audio waveform
where we can impersonate them using their
own voice.
So, what else is there to do in this domain?
Are we done?
No-no, not at all!
Hold on to your papers, because with this
amazing new technique, what we can do is look
at the transcript of a talking head video,
remove parts of it or add to it, just as we
would edit any piece of text - and, this technique
produces both the audio and a matching video
of this person uttering these words.
Check this out.
It works by looking through the video collecting
small sounds that can be used to piece together
this new word that we’ve added to the transcript.
The authors demonstrate this by adding the
word “fox” to the transcript.
This can be pieced together by the “v”
which appears in the word “viper”, and
taking “ox” as a part of another word
found in the footage.
As a result, one can make the character say
“fox” even without hearing her uttering
this word before.
Then, we can look for not only the audio occurrences
for these sounds, but the video footage of
how they are being said, and in the paper,
a technique is proposed to blend these video
assets together.
Finally, we can provide all this information
to a neural renderer that synthesizes a smooth
video of this talking head.
This is a beautiful architecture with lots
of contributions, so make sure to have a look
at the paper in the description for more details.
And of course, as it is not easy to measure
the quality of these results in a mathematical
manner, a user study was made where they asked
some fellow humans which is the real footage,
and which one was edited.
You will see the footage edited by this algorithm
on the right.
And, hm, it’s not easy to tell which one
is which, and it also shows in the numbers,
which are not perfect, but they clearly show
that the fake video is very often confused
with the real one.
Did you find any artifacts there that give
the trick away?
Perhaps the sentence was said a touch faster
than expected.
Found anything else?
Let me know in the comments below.
The paper also contains tons of comparisons
against previous works.
So in the last few years, the trend seems
clear: the bar is getting lower, it is getting
easier and easier to produce these kinds of
videos, and it is getting harder and harder
to catch them with our naked eyes, and now,
we can edit the transcript of what is being
said, which is super convenient.
I would like to note that AIs also exist that
can detect these edited videos with a high
confidence.
I put up the the ethical considerations of
the authors here, it is definitely worthy
of your attention as it discusses how they
think about these techniques.
The motivation for this work was mainly to
enhance digital storytelling by removing filler
words, potentially flubbed phrases or retiming
sentences in talking head videos.
There is much more to it, so make sure to
pause the video and read their full statement.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!